this is DeSean Jordan catch me with a
bootleg Kev podcast
in here professional skater Arizona
native
rapper
yeah we get the [ __ ] TV going over
here
DeSean Jordan
welcome thank you for having me bad year
for Deshawn's huh huh I don't know that
DeShaun Watson Ain't having a great year
he ain't holding it down for the subs
but
hey welcome man so what part of easy
from uh from Chandler so I was born in
like Glendale area and I moved and then
I moved to like Macon Georgia for a
little bit and then Tucson Georgia yeah
oh [ __ ] it was random from there oh for
real yeah I spent a little time there
probably like a year at the most and
then I moved to Tucson with my grandma
and then ended back up in Phoenix oh
[ __ ] shout out to Tucson yeah Tucson so
where did you go to High School uh
Hamilton High School that's a Hamilton's
like a good school right yeah yeah it
was like over in like the Chandler area
no I don't know where Hamilton is that's
where all the [ __ ] football players
went yeah it's like if there's like
somebody who makes it out of Arizona and
makes it to the NFL they went to
Hamilton isn't that where Terrell Suggs
went yep uh Hamilton High School you
have two yes I was out of there and
Chandler has some some fire offs too
they sent a bunch of people to the
league yeah yeah Arizona's got some good
football school Saguaro and Chandler him
but yeah yeah there's a Hamilton
Chandler rivalry like pretty real yeah
it was real like especially when I was
in like high school too which is I mean
it wasn't that long ago like 2015 like
about 10
it was like still going on but even
before that it was like heck the guy
remember being in like Elementary or
Junior High and like going to football
games with my cousin and it being like
the biggest football game like in the
city yeah Chandler is like an
interesting area because it's
technically the suburbs but there are
some like interesting pockets of
Chandler where things get a little hairy
yeah oh for sure it definitely got their
pockets like it's down pockets it's not
a lot but it's it it's there there's
some there's some uh teethless [ __ ]
meth heads over there in fact especially
like after like I feel like it's like
two sides of Arizona average like the
Arizona Ave part that goes up towards
like I won't say then the one that
starts getting like closer and closer
Chandler High School area yeah it gets a
little Chandler's like the hood school
right uh yeah if you had to if you had
to say out of the two yeah Chandler's
definitely more like on that I went to
school in Mesa so I went to Westwood
which was like uh
like Mesa has like the up-to-date
schools which is like Red Mountain and
uh Mountain View and all the Mormons go
there well Mormons go to school
everywhere in Mesa that they just
they're [ __ ] town and then like the
hood schools are Westwood and Mesa Mesa
High but Chandler is like you know sits
on [ __ ] thing oh East Valley though
yeah oh yeah I spent time only time I
was really amazed because when I went to
like skating park yeah oh next to my
house that skatepark uh Reed oh Reed I
didn't really go to read I was mostly at
like Skateland oh yeah because I was
running [ __ ] over there
the I was roller skating I was roller
skating with the homies you weren't
going over there when they were doing
the club glow [ __ ] it was like a bunch
of [ __ ] 13 year olds in there [ __ ]
sucking dick my sister got pregnant at
13 from going to Skateland shout out to
my niece Serena
yeah I don't know I think I was on the
on the skate ring remember when they
were doing Club Globe yeah yeah yo Club
glow was crazy that was like every
weekend there with the homies like
[ __ ] going on it'd be like overnight
[ __ ] stays at Skateland and my mom
would say yes and now we have a I have a
niece
the overnights the all-nighters for sure
my parents they did a great [ __ ] job
my sister got pregnant at 13 I had a
baby at 18. great job guys great [ __ ]
job anyway so wouldn't you start skating
um I started skating probably like like
on the board uh probably like 10 12
years ago I lived in Tucson actually
when I picked up my first skateboard uh
like the group of homies I hung out with
out there we were always doing something
like different like whether it was like
skating or you know everybody was like
on the club Basketball Club football
team and the homies just started
randomly skating and like I remember I
pulled up on them one day and I saw the
board and I was like oh like you know I
mean I've always been intrigued with
like adrenaline rush you know I mean I
always been an adrenaline junkie and so
I used to just grabbed the board like
while they were hooping and just roll
around on the basketball court and then
I just like got hooked on it every time
I linked I couldn't put it down I never
had my own I was always using the homies
boards and then when I moved from Tucson
to Phoenix I kind of like saw more
skating went to my first like actually
this was probably like
man I want to say
2010 oh [ __ ] okay yeah probably around
there like I'll when I moved to Phoenix
from Tucson yeah uh I moved I removed
when I came I was in Chandler but I
lived in Glendale before I like moved
but when I moved back I was in like
Chandler area of course on that side
though closer to Chandler High nice and
then I moved like on the other side when
I started going to Hamilton so uh yeah
because most people like I mean that's a
pretty short skating Journey for you to
be like as [ __ ] popping as you are
yeah most people like man I've been skin
so I was eight years old a lot of my
homies actually are like I'm with they
all started like when they're super
younger I always tell people when they
ask me how long I'm like I feel like I
kind of started like later than most
people yeah and I don't know like it
kind of just
like zoomed like you know I moved here
in 2015 right after I graduated high
school and I was already skating and
started competing and stuff but I would
say like after that two years of living
here of just like you know grinding
filming and linking up with homies like
they kind of just like grinding and
literally grinding yeah for real and
then they're just like I don't know now
I'm here I always trip out hey guys we
got to stop the interview to tell you
about our good folks over at
bluechoo.com that's right listen you got
to go to Bluetooth right now sign up for
uh Bluetooth with the promo code bootleg
you're gonna get your first month for
free Bluetooth the same active
ingredient as Viagra Ana Cialis but in a
chewable form that's right you pop the
blue Chew Chew that thing wash it down
with your beverage of choice and then
get to work with that hard [ __ ] [ __ ]
of yours your dick is going to be harder
than trigonometry was in high school
ladies and gentlemen it's gonna be
[ __ ] Raw like you know uh Ryu and
Street Fighter he'd be like how do you
can he does the [ __ ] this is
gonna be your dick it's gonna be like
ryu's [ __ ] uppercut you know what I'm
saying God bless whoever's on the
receiving end of that consensually of
course uh they're gonna thank you for
taking the blue shoe so go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
all right I'm talking free month right
to your doorstep in discreet packaging
no awkward doctor's visits all right
it's all online you don't have to worry
about going and sitting in a waiting
room and be like hey Doc uh my dick I
could use a little a pep in my step and
then it's awkward you gotta look at this
old [ __ ] talking about your dick he
might ask you to pull it out who [ __ ]
knows what's going on at Bluetooth none
of that's happening boochu.com and they
also got the new brand new
a mint flavored chewable which has
vardinophil in it which is the same
active ingredient as Levitra and staxin
which is a little more potent a little
more potent if you need the extra on top
of the extra you know what I mean get
the mint chewable yeah your wife will
thank you your girlfriend no thank you
your boyfriend will thank you whatever
the [ __ ] you're [ __ ] I'll thank you
as long as it's legal all right let's
get back to the interview go to
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg that's
it have you been in a video game yet no
uh I had one homie not like me as a
character but I had one homie hit me up
they had this games called sessions come
out and that's what I think it was on
Xbox and stuff and he like did a trick
was called like a laser flip on a set
and then after he landed it was like you
completed the DeSean Jordan Challenge
and I didn't know like they had it in
the game until you told me that my big
bro TJ and I was like what the heck like
they put that in the game and he was
like yes
nah they didn't pay me
over there guys now that they were
trying to like having get in the game
but like it was something like my agent
um was like talking with him trying to
figure out like how they would run and
how they do it and now they got a skate
a new skate game yeah I need to skate I
need to be in the sky but hitting up all
the homies so I feel like might be
connected and then they all be like oh
we'll let you know it's like kind of a
minute until until it comes out so I
used to be like my so my childhood
skaters were separate from like hip-hop
people okay it was very like divided
we'd be like [ __ ] the skater like when I
was like eight nine the older people I
would hang out with it was like such a
like there was like a point in time
in my childhood where like skaters were
looked at as like totally opposite of
like the [ __ ] guys who like
did [ __ ] like yeah you know no I
wasn't bootlegging not like 17. but I
was like [ __ ] I was growing up like I
was I lived in Mesa as a high schooler
but before that I was in Phoenix like on
19th Avenue and like Dunlap okay and we
did not [ __ ] with the skaters and then I
moved to Mesa and I'm surrounding all
these [ __ ] white kids we're in DC and
[ __ ] and uh and you know just I think
that there was like a cultural shift
where like kind of the two sides kind of
just merged but like early on skaters
were like this thing that was like over
there yeah it definitely was separated
because I even like before I skated like
I was in like dance groups like I did a
bunch of stuff so when I started skating
it was like in my family everybody was
like oh you skate that I was like yeah
and I was like trying to like tell them
what it was and how it was and stuff
like that so shout out to like guys like
Stevie Williams yeah who really kind of
helped Bridge the Two Worlds yeah and
then I get to give a lot of love to Tony
Hawk the video game yeah because I feel
like the video game kind of made
everybody a fan of [ __ ] skateboarding
facts and then and then Pharrell was
like the guy in hip-hop who like it was
like oh [ __ ] you could be a skater and
be a musical genius that makes classic
yeah he started the whole skate team too
with ice cream yeah so he likes my skate
team in the in the mix you know if you
don't know skate anybody know the Tony
Hawk game like yeah I just yeah Tony
Hawk Pro Skater was my [ __ ] it's still
my favorite it's probably my that's
probably my favorite game ever like I
bought the new re-release oh okay oh
yeah yeah when they released it yeah
that's my [ __ ] man I liked it every
Master they had like a lot of the homies
in there like who like you know in
today's generation of like Street
skateboards oh yeah they put school
people in there so what would you say
like there's like obviously there's like
different genre is of skateboarding
they're Street skating which is more
grinding using like elements that you
would find on the sidewalk yeah rail
stairs there's vert are those like the
two yeah it's yeah it's yeah it's ver
and Street skateboarding yeah and then
there's like bowl is kind of like the
same thing they call it Park but really
it's just like a bowl you know I mean
but it's all it's still transition in
the bowl so it's technically like all
what are you Street I skate both but I
mainly skate Street you know what I mean
so I compete like Street skateboarding
and everything but I like skating both
they're both fun to me so and I kind of
grew up skating transition because of my
local skate park in Arizona was all like
transition right so I like kind of
started getting into Street
skateboarding after that so you never
went to Reed Park in Mesa uh a couple of
times when I was younger but I never
really spent time at the park man yeah
that Park's like that Park I used to
walk there every night and play
basketball with a bunch of [ __ ]
Pisces I was like the only guy who spoke
English I was like [ __ ] 12 hooping
with a bunch of like shout out to all
the Mexicans in Mesa all the guys were
like shorter than me so it's kind of
tight you know what I mean
you know they're dunking up people oh
man but then but yo what's crazy is I
moved to Mesa right before Reed park
opened so me and my boys I thought I was
like oh let me try skating I'm like I
feel like I I I could at one point in
time I could pull off a kickflip I could
I could still probably Ollie but my
skating career was short because we went
to break in to read before it opened but
it was still like you could see that oh
it's a skate park I just gotta hop over
the fence but it wasn't open to the
public yet so we jumped the wall
and then uh
I think the cops or somebody started to
pull up or whatever's cops up everywhere
over there and uh we try to jump the
fence to to run and my jeans got stuck
in the [ __ ] Spike at the top of the
fence I fell eight [ __ ] broke my hand
never skated again well I was like ah
this is not for me I'm gonna just play
Tony Hawk that was a tragic experience
yeah you got to give it a try I guess so
no no no no no no no no no no
this is not gonna work for me you better
just pop it all in for the ground Papa
Ollie I think I could I think I could
pull an alley off hey how about this
Cyrus you can give me that [ __ ] look
over there let's put some [ __ ] money
on it
I could I think I could steal all this
yeah I saw you at Thai I saw you had
title did they tied on the board yeah
there's some good rappers uh Hopsin Rich
the kid solid Rich the kid be like Trey
flip downstairs like yeah I think I
think Hopson could get him though yeah I
think those are the two best that that
would be I think a good game with skate
is actually really good he's not as good
as as Hopson though well you know what's
crazy is like out so like Ty and when
we're on the same session and it was
funny because like I don't think like Ty
knew how good like Wayne is because
Wayne like Wayne be going to Tampa skate
park but he like skate skate like when
you go to the park like he's sliding the
rail like he's jumping down the stair
like and it was just crazy because Tyler
was like dang he was like man like I
gotta I gotta roll down that one right
there and I'm like yeah we could get you
there like you know me but he'd be like
really like he loves skating like he
tried to pull up many times you know any
chance you can get the skate and it's
cool because like he could roll in Wayne
or Ty
I've known that guy for [ __ ] 10 years
I never knew he was picked up a
skateboard yeah you gotta you gotta see
he posted a video here at the park uh he
was smoking cigarettes on the pocket
like a real [ __ ] degenerate though
yeah he was like yo can I smoke and I
always assume it's weed
of course then he pulls out a [ __ ]
pack of cigarettes from Dubai
smoked three of them in the interview
I'm we're all [ __ ] dying in here
it just smells like my dad
for sure
yeah so who do for you like your
experience who thinks the best skating
rapper
I would say man off the top of my head
like the best gay rapper I know like
I'll probably say Rich because like I've
seen like footage of him like tray
flipping a Seven Stairs you know he's a
beast like you know what I mean I think
people don't understand how good he is
like he acts like Andy it's a skate park
in downtown L.A the barracks yeah and he
like always the tents there there he's a
beast like so people do not understand
Rich the kid is one of them guys he's
better than Wayne that's for sure oh
yeah I am for sure
yeah he skate skate like they gotta set
up the ultra I tried to set this up like
four years ago I tried to set up the
Hopsin verse Rich the kids game escape
and they were talking like stupid money
like I think they were selling like 100
Grand on the line and I don't remember
which side uh was not down but somebody
ended up backing out and but that would
have been epic yeah that would have been
crazy I saw a Hobson at a show I forgot
uh what she Vinnie was but he has
somebody to come on stage and he played
them skate it was like some random dude
in the crowd yeah he does that he would
do that um every tour day he would just
say who wants to play skate before the
show behind the venue just playing Skate
and [ __ ] that's fire that's fire yeah
there's been uh what was the what was it
uh who's the rapper who uh tried to rap
it was signed the current or signed a
jet life uh what was the name of the
skater that turned into a rapper
was it Stevie uh the guy who was on uh
fly Society uh TK TK Kennedy yeah he's
in jail right yeah I think right now he
is yeah yeah yo shout out to him too
yeah shout out to you very like he was a
Pioneer in fact it was like it was him
like obviously like when I got into
skating it was him Antoine Dixon
um Theodis Beasley like Windsor James
and like those dudes were like like yeah
the black skaters who was like really
like okay like you know we can do this
like you know yeah why Society was dope
he had a crazy change yeah all the ice
cream ads like he was going crazy I
think he was dating Angela Simmons at
one point too oh [ __ ] good for you yeah
I think so yeah he was like in the whole
scene like he was like he had a TV show
too I remember he was going crazy I
don't I forget what he did but free him
maybe yeah I don't know I don't know
what he did so yeah maybe not for him I
don't know different about freeing him
hey what up y'all bootleg cab gotta stop
the interview to tell you about our
newest sponsor man shout out to the
homies at hardean Las Vegas that's right
then number one dispensary in the whole
state of Nevada let alone in the whole
[ __ ] country so many choices of
Premium cannabis ladies and gentlemen it
is like how can I put this you walk into
it you go to hardine in Las Vegas
when you're on vacation when you're out
there tricking off whatever you're doing
stop off at hardean tell them I sent you
be like yo bootleg have sent me they're
gonna take care of you at Jardin when I
say selection I mean selection of the
best premium cannabis in the world the
best dispensary there's a reason why
Jardine is world famous follow them
right now Harding underscore Las Vegas
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
that's
j-a-r-d-i-n underscore Las Vegas when
you're in Vegas you have to pull up to
hardine tell them I sent you and get
high off your [ __ ] face I don't even
know what that means how do you get high
off of your face whatever melt your
[ __ ] face off with some of that good
hard Dean y'all go follow them one more
time that's Hardy and underscore Las
Vegas let's get back to the interview
anyway uh So you you're making music now
yeah so what inspired you to make music
so like music been a part of my life you
know I mean since I was younger and you
know with my cousins like they would
like write raps for me like they would
have Little Freestyle circles and I'd
freestyle with them and so I always like
had a passion for music you know like it
just like it's always been a part of my
life and so when I started getting older
I feel like my ears started getting more
mature for music and I actually like you
know wanted to tap in so like even when
I lived in AZ I was starting to like
book like little studio time and I was
like making music and stuff which like
now I listen to it I'm like man but you
know it's all like growing you gotta get
your record so yeah it's all grown but
then I would say I moved you know moved
out here and you know the first friend
group I like became like part of part of
you know I was in music was my big bro
TJ a TJ Mizell he as a well he's a DJ
and stuff and uh I got started like
kicking it with him you know like met
Ferg and you know that team and stuff
you know I was TJ Grand Master yeah a
Jam Master Jay master Jason
Grandmaster Flash
nah yeah yeah yeah he's the Roy's DJ Now
um but yeah I started like kicking it
with who's DJ uh Leroy killer Roy's now
nice yeah so I like started kicking with
him you know I was getting like
constructive criticism from them you
know what I mean they were helping me
like grow you know my bro T was giving
me you know uh feedback fragrance giving
me feedback and so I was growing growing
then I linked up with my bro Pat you
know what I mean who's like was my is my
engineer now you know I mean and we've
been together for a couple years now and
like just throughout that time from that
like having that like friend group it
just helped me like it helped me grow so
much in music and I was like getting
more confident with dropping and so all
the Bros like okay you know we're
getting the point where like you know
like like the quality is there you know
like let's start like planning drops and
stuff and figuring out the best way to
merge it you know I mean with what you
already got going as a skateboarder
because like that like that is kind of
hard sometimes you know what I mean and
so like it was a couple skaters who like
you know tried to make music you know
back in the day and they just came
across like super aggressive and you
know the music wasn't like really up
there you know like they weren't really
skate this much so it kind of left like
a bad taste in skateboard's mouth you
know what I mean and so every time
somebody said they made music it was
like oh like don't be you know don't be
a TK don't be a Jimmy Rogers and so like
that was always imprint in the back of
my head so you know I'm a super patient
person you know what I mean and you know
I believe in no God's time is the right
time time and so it's like I just you
know waited you know worked hard you
know I mean had my friend group I was
around and the team I'm with and so
throughout the years of just you know
building getting the Reps and you know
we ended up at the point we're like okay
like let's drop you know the first song
and get into it and so
from there it kind of just was like you
know I just have like a passion for
music you know I mean like I like
literally love music and so with that my
whole thing was like yo like this is a
part of me and I really want to
introduce it in the right way so like
like let's take those necessary steps
you know I mean and have the patience
store like when I do it it's like
respected you know it's not like I don't
get that stigma I don't get that like
you know that opinion and so yeah I just
started you know dropping music and
stuff and you know it's been you know
merged into like my world my Skating
World you know I mean good and got the
support of like the skateboarding
Community some contents I'm in like X
game shows love you know Street League
shows love and so now I'm here where
it's like I feel like it's like properly
you know been merged in and so you know
I'm still grinding you know I know that
trans that that crossover isn't easy you
know I mean but I'm willing to put in
the work you know I mean to like put the
music out so that people can like you
know get that feeling of that passion
through you know I mean and passion will
be expressed through it so you know I
wake up you know I go to the gym at like
seven you know eight in the morning from
there I go stay all day and you know I'm
at the studio all night so fun life yeah
so I just wake up I go skate all day and
then I go rap
[ __ ] so great you don't have any kids no
that's great God bless you
I'm [ __ ] just so jealous right now I
wake up I got two kids to worry about I
gotta worry about keeping my wife happy
[ __ ] 11 people I gotta help with so
much yeah well shout out to you man yeah
so it's a blessing man like I'm
surrounded by a great group of people
and so when you go skate all day are you
just practicing are you filming content
or um like both you know so like some
days we have sessions where we don't
even film some days we have sessions
where it's like oh like I want to get an
edit done today you know what I mean and
like we'll make an edit and post it but
every day is really just like skating
you know fun just like keeping it fun
and music helps me you know also keep
skating fun because I have another
Outlet you know that I'm like passionate
about so like it's the same Stoke like
when I'm skating I'm stoked to go to the
studio you know I mean when I'm at the
studio at night like I'm stoked to get
on that board the next day you know so
it's cool that's kind of how like you
know like even like somebody like Ty is
like when we started like linking up you
know the first thing I was like yo like
let's Skate let's you know like pull up
and skate you know what I mean and so
like we just like kind of built our
friendship through that you know with
music not even being like anything you
know and so just like having that
friendship based off that you know I
mean him being in my world and me being
able to be a part of his world like the
constructive criticism and just the
friendship in general it's just like
inspiring to me and it helps me you know
I mean just like grow and push myself
and you know I tell all the homies
that's a part of my friend group and you
know new people I meet I'm like yo like
if like when I send you music like bro
like tell me tell me if it sucks honest
feedback is like bro I love it like I
it's make me great like let's do some
honest feedback of your music right now
let's do it what song do you want me to
listen to uh I mean the new one I just
dropped better position just came out
with a music video That's the newest one
this is live feedback I'm gonna be
honest with you yeah you know I love it
all right it came out five days ago yeah
where'd you shoot this at uh Arizona all
of it looks like Arizona this looks like
Arizona throw that [ __ ] on the big TV
let's do big TV
so
yeah you just yeah I could I could do it
I'm pretty good with that remote
all right we're gonna do some honest
feedback
as DJ head would like to call it yeah DJ
hey shout out DJ hey
all right
this is gonna be good I'm excited I'm
not gonna lie dude I heard you were a
skater and you're from Arizona and I was
like I'm in let's go appreciate it
Arizona love I'm gonna be honest if
anybody's from Arizona is doing [ __ ]
they have a uh open chair here always
appreciate it biased
hey Z uh all right DeSean Jordan
here it is let's see
which mountain is this
that was some Mountain they found in
like
Scottsdale area the homies just kind of
like like location scout and stuff the
homies who like film the video
[Music]
sick car I like the car so far
the music hasn't started yet
yeah
there's it okay
okay
you've been abducted yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a good day today
[Music]
decisions
[Music]
I like the video
I like this I mean it's a good record
thank you
it's like remind gives me some like uh
you know like kind of like some like uh
cardi you know uh you know some some
young some young boy [ __ ] for sure yeah
yeah it's not bad you know what the
person to ask would be Cyrus Flores over
there because all he does is listen to
sophago and you eat
[Laughter]
appreciate it it was solid appreciate it
yeah that was I'll tell you this it's
better than 99 of the [ __ ] coming out of
Arizona
appreciate it yeah thank you impressed
the video was super dough who did the
video uh overcast are they from amazing
yeah they got that channel um with the
umbrella yeah with the umbrella yeah
yeah so like yeah we just dropped that
one we got like I mean I don't know we
probably like probably got like over
like a hundreds like songs like I
literally like to try to record every
day but like this was probably the last
one I dropped was like a a more Anthem
turn up and this was probably like the
last Anthem turn that we're gonna do and
then like the next step I'm coming out
is like r b like feel good music because
like that's kind of in my pocket because
I really like be singing and stuff but
I'm gonna like slow it down and go back
to like dance hall Vibes and stuff
because like that type of music I like
making along with this but I really just
like I said like I make it and like I'll
send it like Thai or like the homies and
get the feedback my Bros in the studio
you know what I mean Pat like all the
engineers there and then we just kind of
like based the rollout plan off that
it's like I really like you know I mean
I really like being there locked in just
trying to make sure I'm making the best
music you know I mean like right like
you're writing everything are you
punching in uh like I'll go in the
studio put the beat on punch in probably
like six different reps so like
different Melodies and figure out which
one we're gonna go with then just like
go from there but like yeah I love music
and that's my whole goal is just to like
you know like I know like I said I know
it's the crossover is always hard it's
like oh skater actually trying to be but
like I'm willing to put in the work you
know I mean it just it's definitely hard
man because people are already gonna
just have I wouldn't even tell anybody
you're a skater like if you meet them
through music just tell them you're a
muse and then if they happen to find out
you're a [ __ ] huge skater and like
and that's kind of how we like do it we
just spend it like I show the music the
music I make it separate and if people
like people come in off the music and
then find out our skating that's good
then skating vice versa so you know just
really just trying to like make sure to
go out the most natural way and just
like you know doing a do it at a point
to where it's like undeniable you know
like it's like you're gonna feel the
passion through like the work you know
what I mean and understand that like you
know how we're dropping the quality of
things is like I'm not just like trying
to that was better than you eat thank
you I'll tell you that
you're the one who put me on to eat
you're like yo this dude's fire this
dude's fire bro you should interview him
and I dm'd him I was like yo yeah of
course he didn't reply he's too busy
[ __ ] being Yeet you know but that's
better than you eat thank you appreciate
it Hey listen I think also think it
happened to be on the island by myself
where I think Playboy cardi makes some
of the worst music I've ever heard in my
life better than Playboy cardi ladies
and gentlemen
at least better than a whole lot of red
that's for [ __ ] sure appreciate it
hey we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our partners at
Odd Socks our presenting sponsor here at
the bootleg hit podcast listen Christmas
Time's approaching faster than you think
I mean we're like [ __ ] a month and a
half away or some [ __ ] whatever uh get
some Odd Socks for your folks go to
oddsocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and you'll save 20 off at
checkout the most comfortable socks in
the world that's right
we got some Scarface socks they got WWE
yeah I mean they also got the Cheech and
chongs they also got the Flamin Hots for
you hot Cheeto eating [ __ ] out there my
favorite just the odd Sox Basics they're
just so comfy
literally the most comfortable sock in
the world I'm holding the [ __ ] sock
right now you can save 20 off plus they
got boxers now baby all right go to Odd
Socks official.com promo code bootleg at
checkout save 20 off and support our
family at odd Sox and the podcast at the
same [ __ ] time let's get back to the
interview
um anyway man
um I know it's a big deal when you're a
skater to get some dope sponsors who are
you sponsored by
um sponsored by a-shock uh who are these
people because I need a [ __ ] energy I
got you I get you a box for sure no no I
don't need a box I need a check anything
I don't want a box well you never know
if you like it we gotta figure it out I
drink energy drink every and there's no
sugar I drink these have you had well
obviously you haven't had them because
but if you've seen the ghost energy
drinks I haven't actually made them
shits is so gas
I've been damning these [ __ ]
like bro I'm holding your can and
[ __ ] 90 of my interviews because it's
like my drug every day I gotta wake up I
gotta [ __ ] drink a ghost otherwise
I'm a [ __ ] zombie it could be a shock
yeah
put it together hey shock
uh okay besides uh this energy drink
um Essentia water or a water company
[ __ ] that's the but we call that angel
tears yeah yeah essentially it goes yeah
Nike SB I mean that's a big one they
don't have I mean Nike SB is like how
many they don't have a lot of skaters do
they yeah they do uh they have a good
team you know like man the list I want
to name the list because I might you
know do you like get free SBS yeah so if
they drop a [ __ ] colorway you can get
them yeah wow yeah I skate and dunk so
really like I mean I could like skate in
all the shoes but the only skating like
normal dunks uh yeah SB dunk so like I
always just get like all the dunks and
they come out you know I mean like oh
like they're normally send me something
like you're saying I'm a nine damn you
got a tiny
to your crib I can't say where you live
my bad yeah yeah yeah I got the dog song
I'm like yo what are we doing here
yeah so if you get some 12s by accident
just send them my way I got you maybe I
might just have to ship you a little you
know careful you tapped in with p-rod
yeah I was just kicking with him last
night that's that's my big homie like we
skate together every day we kick it like
I was just actually talking to my my bro
pal in the way here I was like bro like
last night it just dawned on me I was
like bro like
I grew up it was me I was me him uh Tori
and Tori Powell yeah and I was just
kicking with them you know they just
putting on Old skate videos just
watching filming like my oh geez who
really took you know skating that level
and it was I was one of them ones I was
just tripping like you know got in the
hot tub just chopping up just about
career stuff and I was like bro like
it's a blessing to be here I'm just like
kicking it with like my favorite skaters
right now you know like sometimes it'll
just be tripping me out and that's funny
you said that because I literally just
with them last night yeah I mean he's
the guy when I think of like Nike
skating I think again yeah me and him
are only shark together it's just me and
him right now the only two people on it
yeah that's big yeah who do you have
like uh on the Mount Rushmore of Street
skating
man Mount Rushmore Street skating
I might even go over because I got I
have a solid I'd say probably like four
okay mine is
Paul's up there for so
p-rod Eric costan guy Mariano okay
Heath kirchhar Mark Johnson like those
that those like those are like my list
and those like when I think about it
just like not only like tricks right but
Style just like you know how I had Eric
Austin Shoes yeah at some point in time
he had he had a fire shoot was he
Etnies uh no he was on uh no Eric Costa
was on uh s yeah it was s that's what it
was I knew there was an e
[Laughter]
um yeah Eric Austin I'm trying to think
what about on the vert side obviously
Tony uh the first shot yeah Tony
obviously like you know OG Legend
Pioneer I would say Bob Burnquist
Burnquist was that guy he's Brazilian
right yeah I think I used to be him on
Tony Hawk he's like King and Amber so I
went there for a contest and like
they're like yeah they're gonna have
like a little function at like Bob's
Island because the guy who I always
wanted to party with as a kid Chad Muska
what what would he think Chad musk uh
Street skating street legend he pulls up
like some of the uh skate contests and
like kicks on the side and watches it
he's still laid back oh just Vibes I
remember him having some fly [ __ ] too
some gear Supra yeah yeah the musket
highs yeah yeah yep yep yep damn the
super era of Life yeah Super Crew era it
was like Supra crew
um and I was I wrote I rode for them for
a little bit when I was younger yeah so
it was like that was like Anton and all
those dudes are still on like I remember
going and seeing like TK at the
warehouse and being like Oh my God like
right TK like Antoine like and those
like those dudes had like the best
selling shoes on super too what would be
advice you would give some kids that are
skating they're 12 13 15 they're just
skating enjoying it but they maybe they
want to figure out like try to explore
you know a professional route
man my advice would say is like
stay true to yourself you know I mean
stay hungry stay humble I uh don't put a
date on success you know what I mean and
don't don't don't do things out of
expectation you know I mean in like you
know just grind like hard work never
goes unnoticed you know I mean I feel
like I've been on both sides of it you
know what I mean just like
like dreaming about that time to come
and like comparing myself to people and
I had to like get out of that like state
of mind just be like yo just like stay
on your own lane stay true to yourself
and just grind yeah like people will
notice you know what I mean people will
notice the hard work and I was blessed
to have people around me that like
helped me you know stay on my toes about
that too and so yeah just keeping your
head down man be confident you know I
mean and just believe you know I mean
there's no limit on dreaming and there's
no limit on like what you can do so you
know Scott Scott I always say sky ain't
the limit people say sky's the limit I
say sky ain't the limit you know me
because you could dream beyond that and
just take whatever you want to the next
level so look you got new music out yeah
more coming soon run it up yeah go
follow uh with your IG yeah just DeSean
Jordan go follow these guys appreciate
you pulling up man thank you for having
me King much love there it is yeah what
up y'all we gotta stop the interview
real quick tell you about our good
friends at my bookie that's right man my
bookie is where you want to get this
money and uh enjoy uh being a
degenerate like myself and it's the best
time of the year to be a degenerate
because NFL season is uh obviously we
are in the midst of a crazy NFL season
NBA season just started World Series is
going down and you can get your bets in
right now go to my bookie and sign up
for a new account using the promo code
bootleg that's
b-o-o-t-l-e-g you sign up right now they
will match your first deposit that's
right put in a thousand oh they'll give
you another thousand to gamble with
that's free money free money to gamble
with let's get in on this action man NFL
season I'm loving this part of the year
so much good just everything to bet on
football basketball [ __ ] UFC uh NFL
baseball whatever now is the best time
to get your gamble on so go sign up for
a new account at mybookie use that promo
code bootleg and double your deposit
let's get back to the interview oh yeah
oh we got it hold on hold on yeah I
brought a little gift for you I didn't
wasn't able to sign it before I came but
I bought you one of my Pro boards oh
[ __ ] as a little GIF you know what I
mean
which one which so what what is this is
this toy machine yeah that's Toy Machine
board yeah check it out so watch your
little and then like I said man if you
yeah it's air man I'm gonna get you a
box of these regardless this happens
yeah
that's the orange mango right there
that's personally what my top of my list
for my favorites
oh that's gas
hey so we got him
yeah listen hey hey shock cut the
[ __ ] check I'll hold one of these
I'll hold one of these every episode
right here
every [ __ ] episode I'll be a shocking
yeah or you could just have this one but
this is good yeah
I love energy drinks yeah yeah I rock
with that that's like the top of my list
and they got cherry limeade all kind of
flavors but yeah I'm gonna get you I'm
gonna get you a box for sure I'm talking
about like right when I leave shoot
attacks it's gonna be on the way for
sure there it is man appreciate you
pulling already much love